echemos un vistazo a estos carbó
cationes los carbó cationes tienen una
carga formal positiva en los vídeos
anteriores les explicamos por qué y cómo
éstos son carbonos que tienen una carga
positiva observen que sólo tienen tres
enlaces y seis electrones a su alrededor
sabemos que a los carbonos les gusta
tener cuatro enlaces y estar rodeados
por un octeto eso hace que los carbonos
sean muy reactivos analicemos este carbó
catión el primero es un carbó catión
metilo voy a escribir metilo
si reemplazamos uno de estos hidrógenos
con un grupo alquiló el carbono con la
carga positiva queda unido directamente
a otro carbono así que es un carbono
primario en el siguiente ejemplo el
carbono con la carga positiva está unido
a dos carbonos es un carbó catión
secundario y finalmente este carbono
está unido a tres grupos del kilo así
que este es un kart vocación terciario
si hablamos de la estabilidad el kart
vocación terciario es el más estable
luego está el secundario que es más
estable que el primario y el primario es
más estable que el metilo como podemos
ver al incrementar el número de grupos
al kilo aumenta la estabilidad del carbó
catión a este efecto se le llama hiper
conjugación
y p
conjuga 100
la hiper conjugación explica como la
estabilidad de un kart vocaciòn aumenta
con el número de grupos al kilo dibujaré
algunos ejemplos para entender mejor
este efecto empecemos con el carb
ocasión metilo es un carbono unido
directamente a tres hidrógenos tres
hidrógenos y sabemos que un carbono
unido a tres átomos nos da un número
estético de tres lo que significa que
tenemos una hibridación sp2 estos
orbitales híbridos se unen con orbitales
s a los hidrógenos y en un carbono de
hibridación sp2 hay un orbital p que no
está y divisado
dibujar el orbital t
este carbono está cargado positivamente
tiene una carga positiva y como es un
gp2 la geometría es trigon al plan
entonces este es un kart vocación metilo
el tipo menos estable ahora pongamos un
grupo metil en éste carbó catión
redibujar esta parte de la molécula este
es mi kart vocación
el carbono está cargado positivamente
y como es un carbono con hibridación sp2
tiene un orbital p aquí y en lugar de
unir este carbono al hidrógeno como en
este ejemplo lo uniré a otro carbono
vamos a poner este carbono como
representación del grupo metilo y por
acá está otro hidrógeno entonces este
carbono de la izquierda es un grupo
metilo y tiene una hibridación sp3
este es un carbono de hibridación sp3
eso significa que su geometría es
detraer y acá dibujaré uno de los
orbitales sp3 de este carbón esto
representa un orbital híbrido sp3 que
está formando un enlace con el orbital s
de otro hidrógeno el orbital s de este
hidrógeno se traslapa con el orbital sp3
del carbono
de esta manera
entonces tenemos un kart vocación unido
a un grupo metilo y este grupo
estabilizará al kart vocación
compartiendo un poco de su densidad
electrónica con este enlace sigma aquí
adentro están los electrones y parte de
esa densidad electrónica se comparte a
este orbital de vacío
como el carbono está cargado
positivamente es la carga opuesta es la
densidad de electrónica negativa ayudará
a esta carga positiva para estabilizarse
este es el efecto de hiper conjugación y
tiene mucho sentido porque entre más
grupos al kilo tengamos mayor densidad
electrónica en los enlaces sigma se
pueden compartir con el orbital
molecular p y por lo tanto el carb
ocasión es más estable todo se trata de
cargas supuestas
los carbó cationes son muy importantes
porque se pueden arreglar en los
mecanismos lo escribiré re arreglos
y el primero que vamos a hacer es la
transposición de metilo
transposición
de metilo
si están haciendo un mecanismo que
involucre a un carbó cateo por ejemplo
dibujar en la molécula que uno de los
intermediarios les quede así
pongamos el grupo metil por aquí
y que este sea nuestro carbó casión
este carbono tiene una carga positiva
más o no algunos estudiantes tienen
problema para identificar a los carbó
cationes ya que muchas veces los
hidrógenos no están dibujados pero como
yo les digo que este carbono tiene una
carga positiva significa que aquí
tenemos otro hidrógeno así ya se ven sus
tres enlaces ahora este carbono está
unido a otros tres átomos y es fácil
darse cuenta que tiene una hibridación
sp2 y tiene una carga positiva qué tipo
de carbó catión tenemos en esta
estructura bueno el carbono que tiene la
carga positiva está unido directamente a
otros dos carbonos así que este es un
kart vocación secundario
secundario
este carbó catión podrá experimentar un
rea regló para formar un kart vocación
más estable esta será la transposición
de metilo en donde este grupo metilo
migrará a este carbono formando un
enlace con el carb ocasión dibujemos lo
que pasará los electrones en este enlace
los del grupo metilo se moverán hacia
acá y crearán un enlace con este carbono
que nos quedará bueno si este grupo
metilo migra a este carbono los
electrones quedan por acá
estos son los electrones del grupo
metilo que se ha cambiado de lugar y
aquí todavía está el hidrógeno unido al
carbono y por acá quedó el ch 3 esta fue
la transposición de metilo la pregunta
es por qué el grupo metilo se movió
hacia este lugar bueno porque de esta
manera se forma un carbó catión más
estable
este carbono de la izquierda solía tener
cuatro enlaces pero tomamos uno y como
ahora sólo tiene tres enlaces tiene una
carga formal positiva
así que nuestro carbó catión micro del
carbono de la derecha al de la izquierda
el carbono de la izquierda perdió un
enlace y el carbono de la derecha lo
ganó con lo que este carbono el de la
derecha tiene una carga formal cero y
qué tipo de carbó catión tenemos bueno
el carbono con la carga positiva está
directamente unido a 123 carbonos nos ha
quedado un kart vocación terciario como
ya sabemos los carbó cationes terciarios
son más estables que los secundarios
este es el tipo de arreglo que esperamos
que ocurre en los mecanismos de química
orgánica muy bien veamos otro tipo de
transposición la transposición de
hidruro
transposición de hidra
y que es un hidro bueno un hidruro es un
hidrógeno con dos electrones
dos electrones el hidrógeno normalmente
tiene un electrón a su alrededor dos
electrones
le dan una carga formal negativa -1 se
le llama unión y duro ok
veamos lo que pasa es muy parecido al
ejercicio que acabamos de hacer si
tenemos esta estructura y este es
nuestro cargo pasión qué tipo de carbó
cationes bueno tiene una carga positiva
y está unido a 12 carbonos entonces es
un kart vocación secundario y recuerden
que aunque no hemos dibujado el
hidrógeno aquí está aquí hay un
hidrógeno en este carbón entonces qué
significa la transposición de hidruro
bueno si este carbono tiene tres enlaces
uno debe estar unido a un hidrógeno que
puede ser el que se mueva del lugar
al igual que en el ejercicio anterior si
estos dos electrones migran junto con el
hidrógeno entonces tomamos a estos
electrones y formamos un enlace con el
carbono que nos queda bueno
dibujemos el producto por aquí tenemos
un par de sh 3 y estos electrones migran
hacia este lado antes sólo teníamos un
hidrógeno unido a este carbono así que
el carbono de la derecha ha ganado un
enlace
muy bien eso quita la carga formal
positiva y ahora es de cero pero el
carbono de la izquierda perdió un enlace
solía tener cuatro enlaces y ahora sólo
tiene tres entonces se queda con una
carga formal positiva más un nuevamente
clasificamos el carb ocasión este
carbono está unido a 123 carbonos es un
kart vocación terciario que es más
estable que un kart vocación secundario
la transposición de hidruro también es
posible traten de buscar posibles
transposiciones de metilo o de hidruro
en sus mecanismos siempre que pueda